[Musique]
c'était dans les années 90 la chaîne de
magasins à grande surface et leurs
connaît alors son apogée au Canada 60
ans après sa fondation par l'Ontarien
Walter peser 1931 décédé sur la
marchandise à bas prix 25 ans après son
ouverture la marque exploite 60 magasins
et emploi 3000 personnes puis en 1981 la
Compagnie de la Baie du son acquiert la
marque la concurrence féroce de Walmart
le début de la fin de zellerse en 2011
l'américaine target acquiert la vaste
majorité des locaux de la compagnie ces
deux derniers magasins ferment en 2020 à
l'époque ça marchait déjà moins pas pour
rien qu'ils l'ont vendu le cas quelque
chose va très bien tu le vends pas HBC
toujours propriétaire de la marque a
pris bien des Canadiens par surprise en
annonçant de 25 magasins Zeller ce
printemps dans les locaux de la baie du
son il prendront la forme de département
de près de 1000 mètres carrés au Québec
en joue Rosemère Québec Sherbrooke et
Gatineau accueilleront le concept mouche
j'aime bien
je suis contente ça revienne moi ça me
semble être un geste qu'un peu désespéré
puis on va tout mélanger de l'ultra chic
avec du plus bas de gamme j'ai
l'impression qu'on est un petit peu à la
recherche de nos souvenirs d'enfance je
sais pas moi j'étais un petit peu pensé
à d'autres choses je pense pour attirer
ses clients HBC lance la boutique en
ligne
zealers.ca quand tu penses à champ en
ligne est-ce que tu penses à la baie
non mais pourquoi tu penseras sérieuse
HBC pourrait étendre le concept à
d'autres magasins si les Canadiens
réadaptent la marque ici Élise Allard
Radio-Canada Montréal